forced abortions manipulating tenants
and human experimentation re-watching
District 9 might make you question who
the real monsters of the film are after
watching District 9 a few times you may
notice that the aliens have a variety of
contrasting colors painted on their
bodies at the end of a q a session led
by Adam Savage at a screening of the
film an audience member asked if there
was any significance to the variation in
color displayed on the aliens bodies
director Neil blomkamp said that the
variation does not imply a difference in
Heritage or social standing within their
alien Society although the colors have
no significance regarding the prawn
social organization you may have noticed
a sport that pan-african colors of red
gold and green well Christopher Johnson
has a green Hue his friend who was
killed at the beginning of the film has
a yellow Hue and other aliens throughout
the film have red Hues using these
particular colors which appear in the
flags of many African nations could be a
message promoting a more unified African
identity to combat xenophobia and
discrimination against refugees from
various African countries
at the end of his q a was Savage Lancome
confirms that the villainous
organization multinational United or mnu
stamps the aliens in District 9 with a
serial number to identify them in
several scenes Christopher can be seen
with a white property of mnu stamp on
his head with a number next to it this
serial number creates a visual parallel
between mnu's treatments of the aliens
chattel slavery in the United States and
the Jewish people imprisoned the
Auschwitz during the Holocaust it is
clear mnu isn't just using serial
numbers to identify the aliens living in
District 9 but that the organization
views the aliens as property rather than
refugees living in a settlement the
aliens are regarded as something less
than human the stump on their heads
emphasizes his attitude as does the
derogatory slur prawn used by
Johannesburg residents to refer to the
aliens the links to Nazi Germany's
treatment of Jewish residents are also
echoed later in the film when Vegas
tells Christopher he shouldn't go to
District 10. you don't want to go to the
things they don't better
they're smaller than the Shacks actually
more like a concentration camp one of
the first truly disturbing scenes in
District 9 which highlights the social
commentary in the film depicts Vicars
conducting what he calls an abortion of
gestating alien Offspring figures even
provides commentary for the film crew
while the shack Burns saying yeah that's
a [__] sound that you're getting it's
almost like a popcorn uh what the egg
does is it it it pops up shortly after
the nursery Shack is burned we learn
killing Alien Children is illegal but
apparently performing prawn abortions is
simply an mnu policy that vicus Embraces
as pointed out in an analysis by the
artifice although Vegas follows direct
protocol he fails to recognize that he's
Exterminating a species Vegas displays
No Remorse towards his actions
suggesting that he's adapted to the
government's policies this disturbing
scene draws a correlation between the
film and historical instances of force
sterilization as a means of population
control for people of color in South
Africa both during and after apartheid
sadly real world South Africa and the
South Africa depicted in District 9 are
not unique in this shockingly inhumane
behavior for sterilization and Eugenics
programs have also been practiced in the
US on by Park populations as recently as
a 20th century
Vegas employs manipulative methods to
extract signatures from the aliens that
are being evicted from District 9. mnu
determined that they must inform the
aliens of their eviction 24 hours before
they are moved and they must sign
paperwork acknowledging they were
informed of their relocation to District
10. Vegas tricks one alien into signing
by claiming that they will receive a can
of cat food a delicacy in District 9 in
exchange for their signature he also
uses a discovery of illegal weapons in
their residence which marks them as gang
members and criminals to speed up the
eviction process when Christopher says
he won't sign the paperwork because the
eviction is illegal vicus threatens to
take away his son CJ he uses the excuse
for the garbage around the shark who
makes a residence unsuitable for CJ to
live in and that he is legally obligated
to take CJ to Social Services you said
you want to stay your boy is coming down
with me to Child Services
there is to be slightly in a one by one
meter box in District 9 the foster care
system has been weaponized against the
impoverished aliens this mirrors similar
events that transpired in the United
States such as the separation of many
Native children from their family homes
by the government and religious
organizations
in District 9 Johannesburg residents
regard the aliens as violent criminals
and aimless scavengers according to
Human Rights Watch undocumented
individuals living in South Africa in
2008 suffered from similarly xenophobic
violence poverty crime and unemployment
alive in joburg bomb comes 2005
mockumentary shows that inspired
district 9 features interviews taken
from Rio Johannesburg residents speaking
about immigrants these interviews
highlight the poor attitudes about
refugees and migrants in South Africa in
a press release blomkamp said in essence
there is no difference except that in my
film we have a group of Intergalactic
aliens as opposed to illegal aliens
after Vegas gets infected with an alien
fluid that begins transforming him he
begins to adopt the same criminal
behaviors he holds against aliens in
District 9. not because he is becoming a
prawn but because he has become
ostracized and impoverished overnight he
engages in violence to escape the mnu
medical facility and steals clothing a
cell phone and food after escaping
because he has no other choice the
aliens aren't mindless drones as the
interviewees in the mockumentary suggest
they are refugees who lost their social
structure and were imprisoned in a camp
that controls her ability to live and
perpetuates their poverty these are
issues real life refugees must contend
with while living in Refugee encampments
every day so we have
Vegas's statement at the beginning of
District 9 sounds strikingly similar to
what the US government told the
indigenous population of North America
when President Andrew Jackson signed the
Indian Removal Act inciting a massive
false relocation of native people from
their ancestral homes the false
relocation of District 9 also has ties
to South African history according to
the South African history archive in
1966 district 6 was deemed the White's
only District by the 1950 group areas
act starting in 1968 60 000 residents of
district 6 were forced to relocate
because they were black or biracial
their homes were demolished and a new
white Sony District was built in their
place in his q a with Adam Savage
blomcam spoke about how the neighborhood
where he filmed District 9 was
undergoing a force relocation of
residents to government subsidized
housing or the movie was being filmed
the area is called shiawelo and Blom
camps that the neighborhood was severe
really impoverished in fact the Sharks
depicted in the film were once the
actual homes of Shia wallow residents
before their relocation
although District 9 has been lauded for
its anti-racism stance it has also been
criticized for depiction of the Nigerian
residents of District 9 who earn a
living off the aliens leaving critics
and academics divided the male and
guardian points out that's although the
film succeeded in eventually making the
audience sympathize with the aliens the
Nigerian characters in the film were
depicted as being entirely reprehensible
you don't want to play with these boys
they'll catch you in four pieces
okay no problem in the Adam Savage q a
blomkamp acknowledged he was almost
banned from Nigeria because of the
controversy surrounding the negative
depiction of Nigerians in the film The
prawns and Nigerians act as fictional
stand-ins for real world refugees and
migrants who came to South Africa for a
better life only to meet with zenman by
indigenous and European South Africans
in her academic paper Ashton Kirsten
argues the director uses these
stereotypes to uncover misguided
nationalism and change our assumptions
about immigrants of course these
negative attitudes about immigrants are
not unique to South Africa we need only
look to the U.S to see a long history of
anti-immigrant sentiments that has
caused incredible harm to countless
individuals and cultures unlike many
going native stories District 9 isn't
about a man who discovers the beauty in
another culture and Embraces it like
Jake Sully in Avatar all Lieutenant
Dunbar and dancers with Wolves instead
Vegas is forced to see the humanity in
an alien species only after transforming
into a prawn himself the utter discussed
vicus displayed when he sees his injured
arm as transformed into a prawn arm
Reveals His racism toward the aliens
because denies his transformation
telling CJ they are nothing alike when
the tiny alien Compares their matching
arms eventually Vegas's transformation
is too complete for him to continue
denying it and he finally sees Humanity
in Christopher and his son CJ after this
realization vikas treats the aliens with
compassion rather than being driven
solely by self-interest in his academic
paper Laszlo Sabo writes in District 9
body horror becomes a medium for
dehumanization that further stresses the
inhumanity of the colonizers Vegas
transformation into an alien forces him
to confront the inherent racism of his
culture and the self-loathing he feels
that he transforms as a poignant
depiction of internalized racism when
Vickers becomes a science experiment of
the mnu medical laboratory he is forced
to fire alien weapons and even kill an
unwitting prawn in a particularly
upsetting chain of events after an
unused tests are run Vickers is faced
with a choice submits to the agency by
having his organs fatally harvested for
medical research or used his Newfound
alien strength to escape during their
raid to retrieve the rocket fuel
responsible for Pegasus transformation
Christopher sees the experiments being
carried out on his people at the mnu
medical laboratory his horror is made
clear by his dejected stance as he hangs
his head and stares at the corpses of
aliens with the intense firefight
between Vickers and mnu soldiers raging
in the background this history of
experimenting on prisoners is Broad the
Nazis experimented on Jewish prisoners
during the Holocaust and during World
War II the Japanese experimented on
Chinese prisoners in Unit 731 this
history of an ethical experimentation
also exists in South Africa according to
PBS The Truth and Reconciliation
Commission and covered details of the
chemical and biological warfare programs
run by South Africa as apartheid era
governments which specifically targets
hit the non-white population discover
magazine also exposed a long history of
unethical experiments on oppressed
populations in the U.S from the Tuskegee
syphilis study and the cia's MK Ultra
studies to a dermatologist's use of
prisoners as test subjects in the
mid-1950s
discussing his thoughts on District 9
producer Peter Jackson told
Entertainment Weekly it's an utterly
original film in an industry that's
looking to make movies out of every
obscure TV show or sequels or video
games you look at District 9 and it's
unlike anything you've ever seen before
while this statement is 100 true and
District 9 is undeniably inventive it is
also a love letter to sci-fi a genre
Blanc Camp grew up obsessing over as
Empire acknowledged in their District 9
review the film is a treasure Trove of
references to sci-fi Classics like Alien
Nation the fly and robocup for example
the suit figures wears to battle the mnu
soldiers in the film's final
confrontation is a not so subtle though
Marge to the mech suits in RoboCop the
director essentially confirmed this in
an interview with first showing saying
that RoboCop was one movie that strongly
influenced him as a filmmaker blancam
told time how the combination of his
youth steeped in South Africa's
turbulent history and his love of sci-fi
came together and inspired him to create
the Sci-Fi set in South Africa the
result was a truly unique film that
celebrates an unabashed love of a genre
while serving up satirical social
commentary at the very end of District 9
we see mockumentary footage of vicar
showing the camera crew a picture of his
wife and telling them she is an angel
my special angel
she even looks like an angel with a Halo
more the scene acts as a sweet sentiment
showcasing Vegas's Devotion to his wife
this line might also be a subtle
reference to the Halo film project that
fell apart before blomkamp made District
9. although Blom Cam's Halo movie never
materialized a TV adaptation premiered
in March 2022 on Paramount Plus in an
interview with first showing blomcam
spoke about how it was only after his
live-action adaptation of the Halo video
game fell apart that Peter Jackson
suggested he developed a feature
inspired by his short film alive in
joburg bad twist of fate allowed Blom
come to Pioneer his own sci-fi franchise
as reported by sci-fi wire the director
has teased the possibility of a sequel
periodically since District 9 hit
theaters even telling an audience a San
Diego Comic-Con is a very personal film
and it's a universe and a place I find
incredibly creative I'd love to go back
to that Universe blancam continues to
say he is developing a District 9 sequel
in 2021 he even hinted to idea the
sequel would more directly address
concepts related to American history
foreign
[Music]